with over 36 thousand different McDonald
locations in at least 100 different
countries it's only natural that
McDonald's would end up with some pretty
strange menu items we're likely and
maybe lucky never to have tried these
strange bit creations before especially
number one which turned a traditional
dish into a healthy breakfast option if
this is your first time visiting the
things don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
here's 10 most bizarre McDonald's menu
items you probably never tried taro pie
the rectangular fried apple pie has
become a McDonald's dessert or snack
staple something about the crispy golden
shell and the warm sweet fruit filling
really hits the spot
we found one McDonald's pie that we're
willing to bet you've never tried the
bizarre taro pie originates from
McDonald's locations in China truly if
you're familiar with Chinese or even
Asian cuisine the inclusion of a taro
pie McDonald's might sound obvious taro
is a root vegetable similar to sweet
potato but even sweeter it is very
popular in Asian and African cuisines
and it is most noticeable for its color
purple the taro pie looks exactly like
the apple pie we know and love that is
until you bite into it inside the pie is
filled with purple syrup and pieces of
taro reviewers have said that the pie is
pretty sweet but that isn't much of a
surprise for a McDonald's dessert taro
pie has made an appearance in the United
States but so far only in Hawaii it
remains to be a dessert offered only at
certain times of the year
turns out the strangest part of the
dessert is its color if you can get past
that maybe you won't miss having fruit
on your pie EB phileo McDonald's
filet-o-fish keeps meat free customers
happy when in the mood for a fast food
bite in Korea the love of fish between
buns has been taken to new heights with
the McDonald's shrimp burger the burger
was made with a minced shrimp patty that
was coated in panko crumbs and fried
however this burger was suddenly
discontinued and it was replaced by
McNuggets the shrimp burger had a
comeback when it returned a few years
after only this time it was marketed as
the new york burger instead of minced
shrimp the patty was made of whole
shrimp and was topped with an onion ring
the McDonald's shrimp burger popularity
is most notable in Japan
prior to 2017 Japan was struggling to
Main
it's customers as people became more
concerned about food safety the concern
originated in 2002 because of the mad
cow disease scare though Japanese
McDonald's used Australian beef that was
not affected by the disease consumption
of beef at the time dropped
significantly this prompted Japanese
McDonald's to diversify their menu in an
effort to drive sales Japanese
McDonald's restaurants launched their EB
phileo
this shrimp burger got its name from the
Japanese model urea bahara who was
involved in the promotion of the burger
twisty pasta breakfast for an occasional
McDonald's customer breakfast my
standout is one of the most delicious
meals ever that's worth waking up for
however in Hong Kong a McMuffin trio
with a hash brown is far from the only
option on the breakfast menu Hong Kong
offers a twisty pasta breakfast it is a
fixed item on the menu but it is only
served in the morning the one variation
includes the same egg and breakfast
sausage featured in a McMuffin they sit
atop a bowl full of twisty noodles and
broth there are even some veggies thrown
into the mix in China
soup and noodles for breakfast is a
familiar concept in anyone leaving for
their morning commute my opted for a
hearty bowl of twisty pasta breakfast
for a foreigner however this concept
seems quite strange and different from
our usual sandwich or pastry fast food
breakfast options there's also a chicken
version another strange fact is that the
chicken is sliced while the sausage is
served whole online reviews seem to
agree that the noodles are always cooked
to satisfaction and the broth is quite
tasty and less salty than you might
expect
worried people in Hong Kong would miss
their hashbrowns side have no fear it is
included with a coffee and the usual
trio would you try McDonald's soup for
breakfast Mik choco potato this next
mcdonald snack sounds like a treat for
the taste buds especially for those who
can't choose between sweet and salty
with the Japanese macaca potato you have
sweet and salty all and one bite macaca
potato is a limited-edition treat that
was available in McDonald's in Japan and
2016 the concept was similar to Wendy's
frosty with fries you can order the
macaco which comes with two packets of
sauce only this sauce is not the usual
mustard mayo or ketchup you might be
used to having to dip your
rise for the macaca potato the sauce
option is exactly what the name implies
white chocolate and milk chocolate the
idea is that you can drizzle as much or
as little of the sweet sauces on your
classic McDonald's fries and enjoy there
are many restaurants that have opened
with the concept of selling chocolate
treats in a variety of interesting ways
so McDonald's just seems to be doing
their best to stay trending what do you
think have you ever tried a strange
sweet and salty combination like the mix
aqua potato that was absolutely
wonderful let us know in the comments
cheese stars McDonald's cheese stars can
be found in McDonald's restaurants in
Balkan countries including Italy and
Serbia as a limited edition option the
cheese stars come back around in the
menu every so often but their popularity
seems questionable other than their star
shapes cheese stars closely resemble the
beloved McNuggets though they also have
specks of white cheese and the batter
used to coat them Serbs fresh from the
fryer these star snacks will get your
tray smoking hot once you bite into them
you'd see that they are filled with a
white cheese and small amounts of an
orange cheese these are served for two
dollars and based on one review from
Serbia and another from Italy it seems
like the local cheesy eats are much
tastier than this fast food alternative
in Serbia it's quite common to find a
cheese and cold cuts platter sold for a
few dollars in many restaurants
meanwhile in Italy there are too many
cheese incorporated dishes to count with
fresh flavors surrounding you we're not
sure cheese stars would be the top of a
tourist tasting menu nevertheless the
idea of a star filled with cheese piques
our interest enough to venture a bite
would you try it Mick spaghetti when we
think McDonald's a plate of spaghetti is
far from the first thing that comes to
mind yet in the Philippines McDonald's
sells mixed spaghetti as a regular food
item Indonesia also offers mixed
spaghetti but it has been discontinued
McDonald's has also attempted to put
spaghetti items on their menu in Italy
but it resulted in a huge flop it's
surprising to see that the Philippines
had the most success with the dish mixed
spaghetti is served with a class at
McDonald's cardboard box in some red
pasta sauce on top pieces of sausage and
grated cheese it's also often served
with a piece of fried chicken for a
complete
but it's a small enough portion that you
could have it on the side with a burger
that we have to admit spaghetti is
rarely what we look for when we order a
burger in 2016 you tuber furious Pete
vlogs posted a video review him sampling
the Filipino dish his review was not as
positive as some of the ones online his
verdict is that the sauce tastes exactly
like SpaghettiOs at least we now know
that if you're ever craving SpaghettiOs
while traveling through the Philippines
McDonald's has a fix for you black and
white burgers this is a two-for-one type
concept that has been a recurring
limited-time offer in China and is
definitely a bizarre if not unique
mcdonald's menu item the black and white
burgers have mostly been criticized for
their misleading name this item includes
two half-size so-called burgers that are
sold together as a pair the black burger
has a bun made with squid ink and is
topped with sesame seeds while the white
burger is sprinkled with black sesame
seeds so far the name fits but where it
is deceiving is when it comes to the
patties well the black burger does have
a burger patty the white burger should
actually be called a chicken sandwich as
its patty is not a burger but rather
chicken it seems that each time this
item is back on the menu it is offered
with much different sauces so if you try
it you might end up with a black burger
topped with a black pepper sauce and
onions on the white burger you might
have found sweet and spicy sauce
alternatively both of these could be
topped with mashed potatoes and a slice
of bacon these small burgers really pack
a punch for the senses with their
contrasting appearance and flavor
combination mccurry pan McDonald's and
vegetarians sound like an obvious
oxymoron or at least it did until
McDonald's opened its first-ever meat
free restaurant in India
McDonald's is very sensitive to the
dishes flavors and treats that countries
around the world enjoy for this reason
they're constantly incorporating local
food traditions into their fast food
meals according to an article in the
week approximately 42% of India's
population avoids eating meat a portion
of the population is Hindu Fuss they do
not eat beef while the majority of the
population is Muslim and doesn't eat
pork therefore it was decided that the
most effective way of servicing the
entire population was to open a
vegetarian McDonald's this is the story
of how an unusual kind of McDonald's pie
was created the McCurry pan is served in
a square pie crust dish and is filled
with creamy sauce mushrooms pepper corn
corn and broccoli don't let the veggies
fool you though this dish is not nearly
as healthy as it sounds as it contains
11 grams of fat and just under 50 carbs
in one single serving mccurry pan is
evidenced that opting for a meat-free
meal is not always synonymous with going
healthy carbonara icon chicken
it appears that Japan is often subjected
to limited time offers when it comes to
McDonald's menu items one such item is
the carbonara icon chicken that was part
of a promotion including 4 different
types of chicken sandwiches the other
three are as follows cheese fondue icon
chicken German sausage icon chicken and
Diavolo icon chicken although all four
utilized some pretty interesting flavor
combinations especially according to
McDonald standard we found the most
unusual was the carbonara icon chicken
the chicken patty like the fondue
sandwich is coated in a sauce the sauce
is a cheesy peppery sauce meant to mimic
the flavor carbonara pasta sauce but the
unfamiliarity of flavors for McDonald's
sandwich doesn't stop there the
carbonara I con chicken sandwich also
includes scrambled eggs bacon and
mozzarella cheese have we got your
attention and stomachs rumbling it might
be hard to choose which of these
creations are worth trying if you're in
Japan during their appearance of the
menu
luckily each of the four sandwiches are
sold one at a time and for only two
weeks each let us know which one sounds
the most appetizing to you in the
comments section below
pork or chicken porridge for our number
one most bizarre item will give you a
bit of context in Thailand it's quite
common to find a dish called congee for
breakfast congee is essentially a dish
containing meat in porridge for us this
concept is a bit nauseating as the pours
we're used to is more commonly sweet
rather than savory in McDonald's
restaurants in Thailand you can find a
regular chicken porridge offered on the
menu and a limited-time pork porridge
meanwhile in Indonesia a similar item
can be found on McDonald's menus that's
only known by a different name
uber I am in Thailand the pork and
chicken porridge is served on rice
porridge with a fried egg and cilantro
this is a healthy hearty breakfast and
is emblematic of a healthy porridge
craze that McDonald's seems to be going
through and Singapore McDonald's is now
serving a red rice porridge on their
breakfast menu this dish was brought to
McDonald's by chef Anna Lim who
discovered the dish while on a trip to
Bhutan this dish is so popular
Singapore that it's been added to the
American McDonald's menus as of April
2018 while you may have never tried the
chicken or pork porridge you can try the
red rice porridge and enjoy it for less
than 150 calories and that's all for the
10 most bizarre McDonald's menu items
you probably never tried make sure to
LIKE the video and subscribe to the
things and catch more videos just like
this thanks for watching
[Music]